-John here's how it works.
This button is the random
Travolta generator.
We'll each take turns
hitting it,
to select the name of a role
made famous by you,
John Travolta.
-Alright.
-We'll perform a small part
from that movie or show
the best we can,
and at the end,
we'll decide once and for all
who is the better
John Travolta --
me...or you, John Travolta.
[ Laughter ]
So I will go first.
I'll show you how the game --
here we go.
[ Game blipping ]
[ Audience whoas ]
Tony Manero from
"Saturday Night Fever," okay.
I can do this.
[ Clears throat ]
[ Laughter ]
It just feels so weird doing it
right next to you.
It's okay.
-[ Laughs ]
-[ Clears throat ]
[ As Tony ] You know, I work on
my hair a long time.
[ Laughter ]
And you hit it.
He hits my hair.
-Uh-huh.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-That was pretty good.
-It's really good.
-He hits my h-- he hits it.
-I don't know if I can beat
that.
-Ah, you can beat that.
Yeah, alright, John,
you can go next. Here.
-Alright, here we go.
-That's the generator there.
[ Game blipping ]
We give it a minute there.
-Yep.
[ Blipping stops ]
-Yeah!
[ Audience cheering ]
-[ Laughing as Danny Zuko ]
[ Laughter ]
Well, that's cool, baby.
I mean...
[ Audience cheering ]
You know how it is,
rockin' and rollin' and whatnot.
-[ Laughs ]
[ Audience cheering ]
Alright.
Let me start the random Travolta
generator.
Here we go.
[ Game blipping ]
That was unbelievable.
[ Blipping stops ]
[ Audience whoas ]
Whoa.
Oh, yeah,
this is a different Travolta.
Okay, I know this one.
[ As Vincent Vega ]
You know what they call
a quarter pounder
with cheese in Paris?
They got the metric system,
so they wouldn't know
what a quarter pounder is.
They call it
a royale with cheese.
Is that right?
[ Cheering ]
Alright, alright,
you're up, you're up.
[ Game blipping ]
[ Blipping stops ]
Castor Troy, "Face/Off."
Castor Troy.
Now, you're the bad guy.
-That's the...
-That's the -- yeah.
-Alright.
-So you're John Travolta
playing Nick Cage.
-Okay.
-This is a tippy --
This is a tricky --
-Ooohhh-whee, you good-lookin'!
You're hot.
[ As Nicolas Cage ] It's like
looking into a mirror
only not.
-Wow!
[ Cheering ]
How you do that?!
How do you do that?!
Yes!
Alright, John,
for this last round,
why don't we do this one
together, okay?
-Which is it?
-Let's try it and see.
[ Game blipping ]
[ Blipping stops ]
[ Audience ohhs ]
-"Welcome Back, Kotter."
-Vinnie Barbarino!
-Okay.
-"Welcome Back, Kotter."
Here we go. Alright.
-[ Clears throat ]
[ As Vinnie Barbarino ]
Hey, Mr. Kotter.
-[ As Vinnie Barbarino ] Hey,
don't you take a couple days off
and go hang gliding.
-This is good weather for it.
No wind.
[ Laughter ]
What? Where?
Up your nose with a rubber hose.
-Off my case, toilet face.
Want to do this funny dance?
-[ Normal voice ] Let's do the
dance. Ready?
And here we go.
Together: ♪ I say hey to
Bar-Bar-Bar Bar-Barbarino ♪
♪ Bar-Bar-Bar Bar-Barbarino ♪
♪ You got me
rockin' and a-rollin' ♪
[ Singing indistinctly ]
[ Audience cheering ]
-♪ You got me
rockin and a-rollin' ♪
♪ Hoppin' and [indistinct] ♪
♪ Barbarino ♪
♪ Oh, you got me
rockin', whoo! ♪
♪ You got me reelin'
Ooh! ♪
♪ You got me ooooh ♪
Together:
♪ Barbarino, yeah, yeah ♪
[ Audience cheering ]
-The winner!
It is official!
John Travolta is the best
John Travolta there is!